[Music]
folks is interesting to think about
here's the thing here's the thing goes
through people's minds and it went
through my mind
it went through Sharon's mind when
you're driving a crappy car you live in
a crappy house while you're getting out
of that you're living like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else it feels like you're the
only one that's driving a hoopty you
think when you're sitting at the
stoplight that everyone is staring at
your trashy car they're not they're in
their own little narcissistic world
they're actually looking at their phone
checking Facebook to see who liked their
last post they're not looking at your
car they're not looking at your car they
don't care about your car not nearly as
much as you care about it and not nearly
as much as you think they care about it
or your house and here's the thing
it's temporary how many of you out there
everybody raise your hand
how're you driven a car that was so bad
that if you put tires on it it doubled
its value okay driven a car is so bad
that you had to give it a name all blue
the Green Monster the the Swamp Thing I
mean yeah I babe the Blue Ox right I
mean how many had a car is so bad you
had to give it a name I've had I've done
every bit of that I drove a car so many
people don't know what this is I'm so
redneck here's what I did
I drove a car for several years and I
never had any new tires I bought
retreads do any of you even know what
retreads are that's used tires that they
sorta put new treads around but they
would fly off sometimes if they got hot
and blow the tire so you always had to
have a good spare if you're driving with
retreads
I went to college on retreads yeah
yeah so been there done that but the
point is do that with a purpose do that
so you never have to do it again drive
like no one else so later you can drive
like no one else
maybe I'm ki no retreads now yeah this
is the Dave Ramsey show